MEETING TO ORDER WE ARE GOING
TO HEAR A. B. SIX THIRTY FIVE
BY MR BIGELOW HAVING TO DO WITH
A LITTLE CLEAN UP ON SOME FAIRS.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. HERE. HERE
MATHIS MATHIS I'M HERE. HAVING
HIM HERE FLORA FLORA HERE GRAY.
JOHN PLAYER SO YOU'RE HERE
LEVINE. THREE THAT THERE BE
THAT HERE SALAS. ON. TIMES
BERMAN THE MEMBERS MIGHT RECALL
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE CLEAN
UP OF A PREVIOUS BILL THAT HAD
SOMETHING PLOPPED INTO A THAT
HAD TO DO WITH OVER TIME THAT
DIDN'T ALLOW FOR THEN NEGOTIATE
CONTRACTS TO BE IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE OF THE- DISCREPANCY.
THAT MR BIGELOW WAS. FIXING.
EIGHTY NINE NINE YEARS. SO IT
IS VERY COMPLICATED. YEAH YEAH.
THE SHAPE THE PARENTS AFTER
TAKING THE. HI ON BOTH SIDES TO
WORK ON. VERY IMPORTANT ALL UP
AND WE THINK MISTER BROWN FOR
HIS PRESENCE HERE TODAY AND WE
THINK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
SHOWING UP FOR THIS ONE VERY
IMPORTANT BILL TO SOME VIPS TO
SOME PEOPLE. ARE THAT MADAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IF ANYBODY ELSE WAS BECAUSE
SUPPORT. WOULD ANYBODY LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIRTY FIVE THE
MARTINEZ. TO RECOMMEND
CONCURRENT ADMIN GUY. MAYBE
.
YEAH. BY THAT. I. SO THE